active protest unfolding on live
television in russia last night an
editor for one of the country's
state-owned channels burst onto the set
of the nightly news broadcast there
shouting no war also holding up a sign
she's become one of the thousands of
russians arrested or detained for
speaking up against the invasion of
ukraine deborah patta has more
a courageous act of defiance in a
country where there is zero tolerance
for criticism of russia's war on ukraine
marina of sanakova an editor for
russia's state-run channel 1 bursting
onto the set of the nightly newscast
shouting stop the war no to war
before the channel switched to a
different report
in a video posted online before her
demonstration of sanikova explained she
was ashamed of her role in spreading
russian propaganda and urged russians to
go out and protest saying
what is happening now in ukraine is a
crime and russia is the aggressor
country the responsibility for that
aggression lies on the conscience of
only one man and that man is vladimir
putin a russian human rights
organization later said that she'd been
arrested earlier this month the kremlin
passed a law that carries up to 15 years
in prison for spreading any views on the
military it deems false it came amid
widespread protests throughout the
country and almost fifteen thousand
police arrests i have never seen
anything like the act of courage
exhibited by marina of san nicola julia
davis is a russian media analyst and
columnist for the daily beast marina is
facing
incredible
risks to her life her safety her future
she knew that and she willingly took
that risk my hat is off to her for cbs
mornings deborah patter london
boy everybody's giving that woman a
salute because i understand my
understanding that that tv station has
over 200 million viewers something
something like that the number is
enormously high and for many viewers
that was the first time that they'd even
seen any hint that there was a problem
in ukraine you know we have the freedom
of the press here so if that happened
here that person would perhaps be fired
but nothing would be of consequence in
her personal life there you are risking
your life as many journalists who are
covering uh this conflict are on a daily
basis you can't say the word war you
can't call it a war in russia 15 years
in prison go to jail let alone wave a
sign i can't get over the anchor there
with the heart on her shirt i know
tony there's something humanitarian
about their efforts as well so just to
see the words war though is opposed to a
big deal special operation special
operations well done right